it's a pleasure to have this opportunity
to review the findings of the student
review with this distinguished group of
panelists I believe this report shifts
the state of the debate and moves the
burden of proof for those economists who
judge that very little should be done to
stop global warming at least very any
early date because a bateman costs
exceed the benefits of damage avoided I
think it's high time for such a shift I
will argue that the most important
reason for this new conclusion is that
it adopts a near zero rate of pure time
preference the rate at which the future
is discounted solely for impatience
rather than rising income this was also
the approach that proposed in my 1992
book on the economics of global warming
and I'm delighted to see that the stern
stern team has adopted this view in
broad terms I agree with the stern
report's findings although I will
suggest some important qualifications my
earlier study started with a 300 year
horizon because this is the time it will
take for the concentrations to begin
declining again as the carbon dioxide
mixes back into the deep ocean according
to oceanographer or Ericsson quests with
this horizon I got much higher warming
much higher damages that in the
traditional two times co2 benchmarks and
it's absolutely essential to do what the
stern review has done is to go beyond
those benchmarks to the higher warming
the higher damages surprisingly enough I
got damages that ranged very closely to
what the strain review gets five percent
to twenty percent of GDP very late in
the horizon and I concluded that with
some risk aversion the benefits damage
avoided would exceed the abatement costs
of cutting global emissions from their
1990 rate of about six billion tons of
carbon too and that's about 24 billion
tons of carbon dioxide's important to
keep them straight to a ceiling about 4
billion tons of carbon indefinitely that
was a cut back of about eighty percent
from the 2100 business as usual baseline
I reached similar conclusions in my more
recent Copenhagen consensus paper about
optimal emissions I found that they
should be about a forty percent cut from
the baseline in the first decade
eventually rising two sixty percent that
the optimal carbon tax started about a
hundred fifty dollars per ton of carbon
that's 45 cents on a gallon of gasoline
in ninety dollars for a ton of coal and
rose much higher although I now think
that the version of the dice model bills
model that I used for that overstated
the abatement costs so they would not
have needed to raise the right so high
now by now it seems that the principal
reason for the virgins between
essentially two schools of results is
that in many optimization models a
higher discount rate is used so let's
focus in on the discount rate the
tradition is that the discount rate or
you can call up the social rate of time
preference for discounting consumption
in the tradition of social cost benefit
analysis pioneered by arrow Bradford
Feldstein equals pure impatience this
row which is a period of time preference
plus the growth rate of per capita
income x what's called the elasticity of
marginal utility that says how quickly
do you drop off the value of extra
consumption as you get richer I firm
that if you if you discounted something
normal like five percent which economist
typically would immediately respond is
the right rate a kind of range a million
dollars 200 years of now is worth only
$58 today well that's a lot of damage to
impose on the future and our descendants
in order to have a nice dinner at a
restaurant even at one point five
percent at one point five percent per
year you'd be willing to pay only fifty
one thousand dollars to avoid a million
dollars of damage but at least the
future has a chance to be considered and
I agree with the stirring review that
you cannot say well let's look at the
financial markets
see what these interest rates are which
I think bill would have us do the
markets don't exist for things a hundred
years from now the closest thing we have
to the consumption rate of time
preference for transferring consumption
over time is the risk-free interest rate
on US Treasury bills and that actually
does turn out to be about one to 1.5
percent now I also incorporate a shadow
price of capital so indirectly I try to
take account of the divergence between
the return but I won't go into the
details of that the zero pure time
preference rate I agree is that as randy
said the only ethical value for it is is
zero otherwise the future doesn't have a
chance to participate now the particular
way that the strain review applied that
gets us into some tricky territory
however as I said I took a 300 year
horizon what the stern review says is
look out to the infinite future aha well
if you have a zero discount rate and you
go out to infinity things really explode
because what how do you discount a time
stream well you take the annual rate and
you divide it you divide it to
capitalize the present value divided by
the discount rate well if the discount
rate goes almost to zero then you're
going to get almost an infinite
resultant now if you will look at the
bottom equation here and look at that
right hand side what you do if you
divide the total value in the stern
reviews estimates between everything
from now to 2200 and everything after
2200 that's the second part of this
equation it turns out that 93% of the
action is after 2200 well let's think
about that do we really have a very good
feel how we should think about what
happens after 2200 as i said the carpets
supposed to start coming back out of the
atmosphere about that
I'm so maybe some of these damages would
reverse and it's not at all clear to me
in fact I think it's quite clear that
the review does not say right in the
first page of course ninety-five percent
of these effects occur after the end of
two hundred years so that's what we're
really talking about now that's why you
get this puzzle where their damages
range from they start out very low but
by your 200 from now they're five to
twenty percent of GDP and then we are
told that they're five to twenty percent
of GDP now and forever well that's
because by the time you take the rest of
infinity the first century basically
disappears so in short the first major
qualification I would make about my view
of this other study is that it seems to
me that by having not chosen a horizon
of something like I prefer 300 years but
maybe 500 600 years would be better to
include taking in the possibility of
Greenland ice shelf melting and get some
of those effects in which are on those
scales but not from now to infinity it
seems to me there might be a more useful
diagnosis so this might be an area for
additional a research my sense is that
they've got a lot of cushion to keep a
positive benefit cost ratio after all
the benefit cost ratio is 20 21 or well
more it's more like 13 1 because you
take the midpoint of five to twenty
percent of the benefits the damage
avoided compared to one percent of GDP
as a cost of abatement so they've got a
lot of cushion to get a somewhat perhaps
more realistic damage estimate by not
going from here to infinity now the
second question then and Parthiv us
Gupta has raised this was what about
that other element in that elasticity of
marginal utility now partha Gus Gupta
don't nordhaus objected to the study for
having pure time preference zero partha
das gupta said no that's a very
reasonable assumption let's set that at
zero but then shouldn't you have a
higher drop off rate in the
marginal utility this last to save
marginal utility and he suggested it
could be as high as three or four
instead of just unity and therefore that
would get you right back into the much
higher discount rate well as I looked at
this I decided well let's infer in the
United States what's the elasticity of
marginal utility from our tax structure
it will interest you to know that the
biblical tithe can be shown to have an
elasticity of marginal utility of unity
the steering value because each person
gives the same percent of their income
no matter how rich they are when I
compared the implicit last assumed
marginal utility in the US tax structure
I get something like 1.3 5 which is
close to the 1.5 that I use if I take
God scooped a suggested value of 3 then
the people that incomes of something
like five or six hundred thousand
dollars should be paying a ninety-five
percent average tax well that's not the
values of the society has suggested so I
don't think I would agree with partha
the scripted that the elasticity of
marginal utility is too low now there's
a question of when you should act and I
think bill has captured this issue of a
forced draft immediate reduction to keep
the concentrations from rising above 550
parts per million and there's a tension
between that and classic use of these
models which optimizes overtime when you
do what because it can be more costly to
act a more tracks enter my broad sense
on this is that the at the end of the
day in the in the insistence on meeting
the 550 the study may overstate the kind
of carbon tax that is appropriate at the
very beginning of the period it winds up
being something like three hundred
dollars per ton of carbon equivalent I
think it is imperative that we
get on a path with something like at
least fifty dollars per ton of carbon to
send a strong signal and to also send a
signal that this is going to be rising
eventually to 125 hundred and fifty
dollars per ton of carbon but if you
have such a massive initial carbon tax
at least implied carbon tax it might
fail politically and jeopardize your
objective in conclusion then I think
that the study broadly is very much in
the right track I think it's high time
that the center of gravity and this
economic analysis of global warming
shift for the recognition with
appropriate discount rates and the
benefits that the benefits of aggressive
action weren't the cause of abatement it
seems to me that increasingly economists
are recognizing that the dangers and the
so-called fat tails of the distributions
of probabilities as Marty Weitzman was
emphasizing his lecture yesterday
warrant taking out insurance against
possible damages from climate change and
I think that this study makes a major
contribution toward highlighting those
dangerous thank you
is this microphone working yeah it's
okay if I sit down thank you both very
much for the very thoughtful comments I
don't want to take too long in replying
but first I'll try to reply first it's a
rather broad level of where these kinds
of models take us and then comment
briefly on some of the specifics of the
parameter values but the reason I want
to start with the broad level is that I
would be very surprised indeed deeply
worried if a policymaker thinking about
these issues decided that everything
turned on whether ETA equals 1.1 or 1.7
or very close details on pure time
discounting I think that's why when I
presented this morning I said the first
thing to do is to step back and ask
yourself what kinds of risks reductions
can you get for an expenditure of around
1 percent of GDP per annum and I think
that most people would be able to
understand that and they'd be able to
look at the risks and they'd look at the
risks in a much more subtle and informed
way than is possible in the kind of
aggregate models that we build so I
think that's the first way of looking at
these things and I think most people
would find that that judgment was
relatively easy to make and not in a
quite a strong way so that's the first
way to look at it I think is in terms of
sensible commonsensical judgments where
you compare costs on the one hand and
reduced risks on the other where you can
be much more subtle about the reduced
risks and you could be in the model the
second thing is to look at what really
matters in the statements that come out
the other end when you do get into the
model and ask how robust those
statements are what is the statement
that really
the statement is that the cost of acting
strongly now is a lot less than the
damage that is saved or averted we did
provide sensitivity analysis in the
review I will give a copy of the review
to all the commentators and draw their
attention to the PostScript it was up on
the web back three weeks after the
publication of the report it's in the
bound version that came out with CU p
and we do indeed do sensitivity analysis
to what we call the eta's and the deltas
i think it was your seater and ro bill
basically if you if you run eater up to
two or so a bit more in most of the runs
you're going to get that statement
carrying through that the costs of the
action to avert the damages is a lot
less than the damage is averted if you
take a cut off of 33.5 percent on the
damages in order to say it's a lot more
than one percent then that statement
would be pretty robust to a broad
variation of the heaters and the deltas
so to say that the basic argument turns
on the particular eater and delta chosen
does not survive the basic sensitivity
analysis that we carried out on the
question of and i said this morning that
if if the world was left an extern it
would choose nita above one probably
mercifully it's not and i agree was
build if you look at what governments
actually do they don't show signs of a
spectacularly high eater and i gave the
example of what the redistribution ille
implications would be for eater equals
two in a simple-minded way where we
adopt the sort of Okung leaky bucket
view of a transfer and saying how much
would have to leak out the bucket for
you to still think that transfer as
worthwhile so when we make these
consistency tests we should as bill did
ask about consistency with transfer
policy if we're talking about
and egalitarian parameter so I think
that's important part of the story
nonetheless I would vote for eater
higher than one and if you do the
results carries through provided it is
not very high actually because eaters
doubling as risk aversion parameter if
the spreads as a distribution is
sufficiently wide then actually raising
eater raises the damages but that does
depend on the spread of the distribution
and it's cos e 2 e 2 doubles up as a
risk aversion parameter and the
inequality parameter so in the broad
sense i think the perspective which i
began with this morning doesn't need the
details of eaters and deltas and if you
do bring in and you narrow it down to
these models and you look at the eaters
and the deltas then basic sensitivity
analysis leaves the statement that the
costs are much less than the damage is
pretty robust now on some of the again
sticking on the broad issues the
question of peer review we're having our
peer reviewed today bill that's why I
came that's why I wanted to come and
it's why I believe that public
discussion of this is of fundamental
importance the mechanics of government
and I won't go into them here if you
start sharing things with people I'm
this is an observation not a value
judgment now if you start sharing things
with people saying look this is the kind
of thing we're coming up with how does
that grab you all my experience is that
it's in the papers the next day and you
start having these kinds of discussions
not in this kind of environment you
start having them in the columns of the
Daily Mail and the Sun and whatever
corresponds to daily rail in the Sun in
the United States and so I think there
is a problem of combining what I'd love
to have and would have loved to have had
on this thing with the machinery of
government I don't make any comment
about that I mean would that it would be
different I would I'd like it to be
different but it is difficult from
inside government to have those kinds of
sharings that's why
said this is happening after the event
but it's fine as long as the discussion
takes place as long people air their
views and then we're not trying to
disappear from this and indeed that's
isn't as I said before why we're here
the but one or two specifics now do we
know that long run market rates returns
a high like bill I don't know that and
indeed I would add to the kind of
statements that we have to bring into
this if we're thinking the long run
social rates of return on investment we
have to in take into account the
environmental damages which would take
place and that could reduce your long
run rates return way below the private
rates return that people see in the
market so I don't think we know over 100
200 years what these kinds of rates are
returns are but suppose we knew them in
the shorter run and we said we can get
high short run rates return so we're
invest in those will put the climate
change stuff to one side will make these
wonderful rates of returns on these
investments that we can see and we'll
sort out climate change later on that's
the kind of implication of that kind of
argument would that leave us in a good
place I suspect it wouldn't and we want
to try to build into the models in this
case I would suggest a very rapidly
rising price of environmental goods
relative to ordinary goods and we all
know from the basic theory of
discounting in models with many capital
goods I mean falling from muhlenberg
famous article in the nineteen
fifty-three chronometric ax and it's
pretty well it obvious anyway that the
unit of account that you use has a very
striking effect on the discount rate if
you did you're just you did your
accounting and environmental Goods
indeed the discount rate probably be
negative so if you build models where
you underestimate the rapid rate of rise
of invar up the price of environmental
goods relative to other goods then one
way of compensating for that mistake is
to use a low discount rate ideally what
you'd do is to build directly this very
rapidly rising price environmental goods
into the model I suspect people don't
quite honestly so what worries me is
this idea of postponing getting a
thumping great return
your investment and sorting out the
environmental problems later ignores
that real difficulty of how much more
difficult it would be later to spend
your money and get yourself out of the
environmental pickle that you've got
yourself into and finally I'd like to
say something about what radical means
this morning and this afternoon and
tomorrow I wouldn't place huge emphasis
on estimates for social cost of carbon
they're incredibly sensitive it's a
valuable idea we can fiddle around with
it but how valuable it is is it as a
guide to policy if you remember the
argument this morning I said go for a
stabilization goal on the basis of risk
management and cost of getting there
think of the paths that are consistent
with that stabilization goal there will
be a choice of paths consistent with
that stabilization goal use the price
mechanism to decentralize within that
framework and revise from time to time
bearing in mind things like the social
cost of carbon from that point of view
you've got to ask what radical means I
don't measure radical in terms of the
social cost of carbon which is all over
the place and very hard to measure and
of course depends very much on your
choice of path and on the path that we
had for stabilization that the social
cost of carbon started that's
thirty-five dollars per ton of co2
because you were on a more sensible pass
and not on the business as usual path so
these things are very sensible and
difficult at sensitive and difficult to
get your head around I would talk about
radicalness in policy in terms of the
kinds of targets you set yourself for
emissions reductions over 20 and 50
years I would see radical in terms of
what will the European Union set itself
for an emissions reduction in them in
its third phase of the emissions trading
scheme between 2012 and 2020 and we're
talking in Europe about twenty percent
whatever anybody else does maybe thirty
percent if people other people move
strongly and we wait
in strong anticipation to United States
the that's the kind of way I would
measure radical and you'd ask yourself
how difficult is that to do what kind of
things would we have to do is it easier
if we start now and I actually think
that starting now is in some ways less
radical than starting later because if
you start now you can spread your action
out over a longer period of time if you
leave it and decide that the
stabilization goal of 550 actually was
wise then you get yourself into much
more trouble later on so I would see
radical in terms of the kinds of actions
you have to take the kinds of
quantitative goals you have to make the
kinds of R&D you try and do now that's
my notion of radical and I suspect bill
that if we looked at that we probably
radical in those terms we might actually
come up with similar kinds of ideas so I
would not characterize what we did is is
dramatic in some way i think the
policies that we would describe would
look rather similar